so I was cleaning my apartment and
drinking this Smirnoff on my day off and
I got to thinking does Whitney have a
walk of fame star maybe I didn't have
one I mean she's right she deserved wine
and they're doing gonna give her one
that I think that I should and so I went
out and I bought all these supplies I
have a Sharpie so I'm gonna use this
cardboard we don't Amazon box and I'm
gonna make her a walk of fame star WH
ite anyway right there's a little circle
under it and then inside that circle to
draw like the symbol for the thing you
want I'm gonna draw a microphone yeah
looks like a big these are just regular
paper scissors they're not the best
sisters but for then I should probably
the father deserves business you know I
think it's really hard in this trip
really are a bright night
[Music]
come on say don't do that son need the
star and pretty good Tsar I think then
I'm going to decorate it to look better
better than other stars so I think the
best way to do this is this is glitter
glue so stars don't read or I love red
but that's a little boring so I'm gonna
do you know what was just stand out it
doesn't I won't know to be you don't
tell us we won't know looks like it's
stupid hmm
back to Monstar oh I keep hitting the
table on the camera you shaking we need
to hate that sorry
washable faith and non-toxic let's say
about that did so not talk to
I don't know if you're not they
definitely is gross we'll have to clean
this litter out and I looked at a game
for one time look isn't this beautiful
isn't it
Boulevard I'll be Whitney of the you're
a great comedian and a even better
person that's how that's Hollywood
[Music]
Catalans great
you CNN
can I touch it
they thought maybe this
[Music]
you